we'll take one or two more calls six one
seven eight three zero forty seven fifty
is the number we are taking all
questions and comments who's on the
phone with me next and where are you
calling from
um I am Noah and I'm living in
Philadelphia Pennsylvania
all right Noah what's on your mind today
um I just wanted to let you know that
I've been watching you for many years
now I actually I voted for Donald Trump
um I've been I've been watching you for
a really long time and I watch all
different types of independent media and
I just wanted people thank you for
everything you've done and I always take
your opinion into account on practically
everything and I really respect you guys
as individuals and I'll definitely
continue to watch you regardless of how
my views shift and I really just wanted
to thank you for all that
well thank you I mean I'm curious on
what issue made you decide to vote for
Donald Trump um you know like it was
really it was really more of like the
whole politically incorrect like
alternative right viewpoint Wow kind of
that I was into I was at the beginning
but this sounds like you've been you
know I'm only 18 I'm I go to the
University of Pennsylvania yeah and um
and I I supported Bernie Sanders at the
beginning and this whole thing actually
ended up voting for Donald Trump yeah
and it's really a 180 turn around and I
just I don't know it's it's really just
I really like the movement I really
really wanted an outsider just to shake
things up and such and what exactly do
you hope Trump will do now that would be
something you would say oh that was a
good policy thing he did um I'm
definitely looking forward to seeing
what he does in the Middle East and but
what would what could he do that you
would say that's the right thing I mean
it sounds like I mean I'm I'm just as
curious as you like what the hell is he
gonna leave but what would you like to
see him do or you would say wow that's
what I voted for
and I'm glad we got it you know like I
like believe it or not I'm I'm not
really I'm not really a big fan of like
the whole Mexican immigration and such
and all the illegal immigration so I am
pretty you know curious skeptical but
excited to see if they'll actually you
know build the wall which I've been
looking forward to for a while yeah now
did you know that there's a net outflow
of Mexican immigrants like there's more
people leaving the u.s. to go to Mexico
than coming in from Mexico was that
something you were aware of look at the
statistic unfortunately it's too late
yeah no no listen we're not Pennsylvania
is red and that's it I'm just curious
because you know you're expressing this
idea where you just you like the energy
and the movement and you have curiosity
but I'm wondering what is it exactly
policy-wise that you hope Trump will
achieve and you know the wall isn't
getting built there might be some
fencing put up in some parts and you
know Mexican immigration really
mathematically is becoming a smaller and
smaller problem with this net outflow so
I and it's interesting yet what about
the politically incorrect movement
energized you I'm really curious you
know me it's all I mean as awful isn't
me and like I like I have expressed like
I am very moderate like I have listened
to many many sides of the argument but
yeah and if you guys for a really long
time um it's just like the whole you
know just the wave of like of like
feminism and just like politically
correctness and and like say you're not
for only voting for Hillary because
she's a woman and puts it like that like
did you meet anyone who voted for
Hillary only because she's a woman I
didn't meet anybody like that yeah you
know like and what you say is through
there but and I don't I don't think it
was only I probably that was a poor poor
choice of words so when you said you
didn't like it when people voted for
Hillary only because she was a woman
you actually didn't mean that you don't
know of anybody who voted for Hillary
Clinton only because she's a woman and
you're not a feminist yeah I
yeah I miss I miss said bad yeah okay
it's more more like something that I
just see it's such a like I just I see
people that really only like for me I've
looked at so many so many different
sides of media and such and seeing so
many different opinions but I feel like
when people are only subjected to the
you know like liberal independent news
sources and like any any major news
sources they're they're really only
exposed for that and then they might not
actually think about the policy that
much but they might just see you know
Hillary Clinton being this strong woman
and such but no no offense you're st.
your career saying yes sometimes people
might not think about the policies that
much when we asked you why you voted for
Trump you said you were really sick of
the political correctness and feminism
stuff that has nothing to do with the
policies right so it sounds like you're
sort of in the group of people you're
criticizing for not voting based on
policy yeah and you know what like I I
know that I like I know like I
completely agree with you know I mean
completely just Tomales me like no like
I do like I mean what you just said is
correct and that is exactly why looking
all right the pen Pat I know Pat wants
I'll talk to you real quick just real
quick before you go Pat wants to say
something too just in terms of being
politically correct is there a word or
phrase you wish you could say now that
is not considered politically correct
for you to say at this point um wait let
me let me think about your question
there you just mean like a a certain
like these things you can't get away
with saying now that you may have been
able to decades prior prior to give
alittle career you think of some sort of
example of something you wish you could
say now um no but you guys are
ridiculous Martin this is why I listen
to you and I if I paid more attention
called before I actually got to talk
about my views you guys I may have voted
differently Wow Wow well listen in
Pennsylvania I'm not even one vote
wouldn't have made a difference
so at least we can say that even though
it sounds like we nobody can figure out
why I voted for Donald Trump that one
vote would not have changed the election
results and I think for that you'll be
able to sleep easy for the next 40 what
you
literally the things though being able
to express my like what I've my thought
process during the election and such and
you guys debunking that and you're very
smart and formulated way right there
like that's honestly what I needed I
think I can I think I can look at
politics but almost in a whole different
lens now Wow
well for that we can thank Rachel and
Pat listen I really appreciate the call
we've got to run this is endlessly
fascinating believe me but you know it's
it's also very very confusing and it
explains to us a little bit about what
did happen last night thanks so much for
the call I appreciate it Wow
Thank You pleasure smokers a pleasure
thank you okay we we definitely
definitely need a break after that guys
I mean that I think explains to us a lot
about what happened on Tuesday night and
early in the Wednesday hours we will
take a break we will process and then we
will be back